The joe rogan experience.
They would never do that.
Of course you billion is a big number.
I don't know what kind of country you live in.
Separate.
That's what I'm talking about.
Taxes.
My 3 billion pays for social programs.
Clean the streets.
Who Do you want to build these bridges?
That extra 3 billion is important,
right?
The only that they're not going to pay it in taxes.
He this.
It's not like,
oh,
that's right.
They weasel that shit.
Yo me,
come on.
The NFL is like charity.
That's one of the funniest things of all times.
The NFL is tax free.
Is it team by team though?
Do they talk to the dude?
That's the whole thing is a charity organization.
Please
franchise in the world.
The UFC needs to get on that.
I don't know what the Fuck Dana White's waiting for.
We need to be tax free.
We need to be ready.
The UFC shit.
Shit should be a charity.
That's what I'm saying.
Crazy shit.
You imagined the UFC tried to become tax free.
You know who else was like,
oh my God,
the NHL,
they're tax free to,
yeah,
get the fuck out.
And Joe,
that is hilarious.
Mba.
That is that they had to pay too many black people.
They got to fight.
We're not happy with at this 99% black people got dammit,
make them pay taxes and these baseball,
they got to pay to too many Latino,
too many Latinos.
These mother fuckers coming over here throwing heat,
giving up money,
bitch,
give me,
give me that fucking money.
Taxes,
man.
The people that don't have to pay taxes,
it's a real God damn mind blower.
It's like,
well how does that get determined and like religions that make money like
religions,
like say Scientology.
Scientology is a tax payer organization in tax free organization that was
written by a science fiction writer who l Ron Hubbard,
who publicly stated that the best way to make a lot of money is to start your
own religion and he got tax free.
That guy got tax right.
You know what's funny?
When I got out of prison,
I went to try and find a job and all these places and everyone said no to me and
there was this one ad that was like,
come learn the secret to life and get paid while doing it.
And it was like $12 an hour job and like 1999 when I just made parole and they
were advertising like,
please come to this area,
you know you can learn.
And I walked in and it was a Scientology center and I walked in.
Lady was Super Nice.
They're all the most polite,
did you fucker?
They just wanted to fucking sign time.
They just,
they literally just brought me in.
They shoved me in front of a screen with like four or five other people and they
played me like a Scientology video and then they will,
they,
they asked us,
they were like,
did you all understand the truth in this video?
And I was,
I was sitting,
I was just like,
Yo,
I really wanted to be like,
well what the fuck is wrong with you?
Like no one believes this shit.
But at the same time I sat back and I said,
you know what,
I really don't understand this religion enough for me to make a commitment it
right now.
And they were very polite to me.
They're like,
thank you very much for your time,
sir.
Take care of.
And it was somebody else in there really needed that fucking job and they just
looked at me and they were,
they gave him this kind of look like,
cool,
cool.
You're out in the running and went there.
I was touched.
I had to swear to God,
Yo,
I could see the charlatan and the snake oil coming out of the side of the
jacket.
Dude.
They were like,
I was touched by this video.
Like I really thought it was amazing.
The dude,
they're there to get the job,
you know?
That was it.
I looked at it.
You might be right about this racist shit by the way,
because the only other ones that don't have to pay taxes,
the golf league,
the PGA and at the NHL
[inaudible]
hello dad is fucking should be passed.
Yeah.
Doug Golf guys don't have to pay tax like the most money.
Right.
Wow.
That's dark.
That's dark racism.
Wow.
I think it's racism.
I'm crying racism for the NBA and I don't even watch basketball.
Yeah.
The idea that you could get away with the Scientology thing,
that that could be,
we need to start our own fucking religion.
We need to do,
God dammit.
That's how you're really good at the blockchain.
That's how you're really locked down.
That's the quote right there.
When you start a religion,
God dammit.
Well,
they have so much money that they can get away with it.
Like Scientology is a number to land owner in Los Angeles.
They own more buildings and property real estate in Los Angeles.
Then like almost anybody freakiest thing is,
you know how to rope off everything at a time square when uh,
when the ball is going to drop or whatever and there's a certain time you can't
go past the barricades.
One night I was there and the guy said,
well,
you remember the Church of Scientology?
And I said,
yeah.
And he let me in through the barricade.
Real story,
Dude.
Real Story.
He probably just wanted to fuck you.
[inaudible] you're a handsome guy.
[inaudible] button.
What is the,
wow,
what are you supposed to say?
Amazing.
He probably loved you,
dude.
The Scientologists try and make friends.
He was so bad.
It was a police officer too.
That's hilarious.